[Music]
let's explore some of the most common
ways Airlines price flights you won't
believe when you hear that the same seat
can have totally different prices give
this video a thumbs up and hit that
subscribe button to never miss another
video again now don't forget to fasten
your seat belt because we're ready for
takeoff gathering data it all starts
with gathering data about their
passengers an airline can get
surprisingly a lot of information about
when where and why is their customer
booking a flight ticket in the first
place when a lot of data is gathered
they are able to predict their customers
behavior and manipulate their prices to
make sure the airline always makes the
most profit out of each flight through
gathering data is primarily done through
loyalty programs registered users and
browsing cookies with information about
customers age location travel habits and
even random insights but airlines take
many more things into consideration when
it comes to deciding how they'll price
their seats determining the type of
flight if you ever set price alerts for
your next flight you've probably seen
that the price will change depending on
the time you buy it but there are many
other factors that are taken into
consideration for example the airline
kind of knows who you are based on the
destination you take certain
destinations have a marked leisure
profile like London to Majorca for
example the destination itself allows
the airline to identify their potential
customers and their ticket buying habits
the data already gathered the type of
flight and the actual popularity of the
route all determine the cost of the
flight ticket leisure versus business
there are two primary types of travel
customers out there
one is leisure and the other one is
business if most people schedule their
holidays to Majorca months in advance
the airline makes sure that the starting
price is high then the fares are
adjusted according to the seats
purchased however it's not the same for
business lights business traveller is
always booked last-minute and as a
result their prices are always soar in
half but if you booked a trip from
London to Frankfurt a few months in
advance you might be able to get an
amazing
deal while your fellow passengers next
to you will have to purchase a ticket
with a price twice as high important
days of the week you've probably heard
that the price can vary depending on
which day you're purchasing your ticket
according to a survey done by the
airline reporting corporation the most
expensive data by flight tickets is
Friday while Tuesdays and Thursdays are
the best for lowering costs these prices
were first determined by marketing
managers who were responsible for flash
sales and offers but now they are
automated and unified across most
airlines the important days of the week
will also vary depending on the location
of the airline for US airlines Tuesdays
at midnight tend to produce the best
search results but it's not the same for
other airlines around the world other
factors but there are many more factors
that determine the price of your plane
seat if a similar airline has cheaper
seats for that same route everyone else
will have to adjust to make sure their
planes still get fully booked
however for destinations with very
little competition the prices are
typically more expensive and hardly ever
drop of course the longer the flight the
more expensive your ticket will be your
ticket can also become expensive if the
fuel prices become higher as the airline
still has to make some kind of profit
from flying you to your destination
speaking of destinations sometimes a
connecting flight can turn out to be
much cheaper than a non-stop destination
without any lay overs seats apply so
let's have a look at how the airline's
price their seats your neighbor might
have paid a completely different price
to yours even though you're on the same
flight and sometimes they can even
charge completely different fares for
the identical seat
this is known as yield management a
strategy that separates customers into
two categories the first is those that
are willing to pay any amount for their
ticket as we explained before people
like business travellers and celebrities
typically don't care about the price but
if the airline only relies on the first
group they might never be able to fill
as much of the plane as possible here's
when the seating prices start to change
the second group are travelers who are
looking for a much cheaper option why do
the same seat prices
typically the airline will cater to high
budget passengers first and depending on
the demand the strategy will change to
sell as many seats as possible this is
precisely why you might see a
significant drop in price for your
chosen see the strategy allows the
airlines to fly full planes and make as
much profit as possible airlines have
over a dozen fares for identical seats
and they all run at the same time in
order to make sure all these prices
adjust accordingly the airlines run
software programs that will monitor
flights and booking patterns that way
they are able to oversee the behavior of
their customers and predict how when and
why will a person book their plane
ticket what about low-cost airlines if
you live in Europe you're probably
familiar with airlines like easyJet and
Ryanair which will sell flight tickets
for as low as 10 euros in one direction
often described as tickets that are
cheaper than a taxi these airlines work
on a different low luxury strategy that
allows them to only provide the basic
necessities to their customers from
seats that don't recline to the lack of
back pockets allows their crew to spend
less time on maintenance and cleaning
and therefore reduce total costs this is
extremely convenient for shorter flights
and frequent routes but that's not the
only thing that helps low-cost airlines
make profit all while making their
flights it gets completely affordable
type of aircraft low-cost airlines are
also known to buy their aircraft in bulk
which can often affect the price of the
actual affairs they also buy specific
types of airplanes and are therefore
able to reduce their staff training
costs to only those aircrafts this helps
them save money while also budgeting
enough for the expensive fuel and other
costs that come with being an airline by
reducing costs on practically everything
European airlines like easyJet and
Ryanair are able to offer competitive
that can't be beat and since empty seats
cost money low-cost airlines are able to
fully booked most of their flights
without any problems
automated process many of these pricing
systems are totally automated
which is why savvy travelers usually
know how to find cheap flights you
should also always compare your prices
as much as possible to find better deals
you never knew about websites like sky
scanner and the mundo allow you to
easily see all possible fair prices for
your chosen destinations these websites
expose all strategies and make it easy
to find a flight for a much better price
so next time you're booking a flight
ticket remember how Airlines price their
flights and see if you can get a better
deal good luck how do you find cheap
flight deals make sure to let us know in
the comments and that's it for our video
for more videos like this one check out
10 things you should never do on an
airplane see you next time
[Music]